welcome to Simply learn in this video we
are going to learn in detail about
linear regression logistic regression
and see the comparison between them so
before we begin consider subscribing to
Simply learn and hit the Bell icon to
never miss any updates from us let's
look at an example of a common use for
linear regression profit estimation of a
company if I was going to invest in a
company I would like to know how much
money I could expect to make so we'll
take a look at a venture capitalist firm
and try to understand which companies
they should invest in so we'll take the
idea that we need to decide the
companies to invest in we need to
predict the profit the company makes and
we're going to do it based on the
company's expenses and even just a
specific expense in this case we have
our company we have the different
expenses so we have our r& which is your
research and development we have our
marketing uh we might have the location
we might have what kind of
administration it's going through based
on all this different information we
would like to calculate the profit now
in actuality there's usually about 23 to
27 different markers that they look at
if they're a heavy duty investor we're
only going to take a look at one basic
one we're going to come in and for
Simplicity let's consider a single
variable R&D and find out which
companies to invest in based on that so
when we take a R&D and we're plotting
The Profit based on the R&D expenditure
how much money they put into the
research and development and then we
look at the profit that goes with that
we can predict a line to estimate the
profit so we can draw a line right
through the data and when you look at
that you can see how much they invest in
the R&D is a good marker as to how much
profit they're going to have we can also
note that companies spending more on R&D
make good profit so let's invest in the
ones that spend a higher rate in their
R&D let's look at another example of
machine learning based on the amount of
rainfall how much would be the crop
yield so here we have our crops we have
our rainfall and we want to know how
much we're we're going to get from our
crops this year so we're going to
introduce two variables independent and
dependent the independent variable is a
variable whose value does not change by
the effect of other variables and is
used to manipulate the dependent
variable it is often denoted as X in our
example rainfall is the independent
variable this is a wonderful example
because you can easily see that we can't
control the rain but the rain does
control the crop so we talk about the
independent variable controlling the
dependent variable let's define
dependent variable as a variable whose
value change when there is any
manipulation in the values of the
independent variables it is often
denoted as Y and you can see here our
crop yield is dependent variable and it
is dependent on the amount of rainfall
received now that we've taken a look at
a real life example let's go a little
bit into the theory and some definitions
on machine learning and see how that
fits together with linear regression
numerical and categorical values let's
take our data coming in and this is kind
of random data from any kind of project
we want to divide it up into numerical
and categorical so numerical is numbers
age salary height where categorical
would be a description the color a dog's
breed gender categorical is limited to
very specific items where numerical is a
range of information let's look at a few
applications of linear regression
economic growth used to determine the
economic growth of a country or a state
in the coming quarter can also be used
to predict the GDP of a country product
price can be used to predict what would
be the price of a product in the future
we can guess whether it's going to go up
or down or should I buy today housing
sales to estimate the number of houses a
builder would sell and what price in the
coming months score predictions Cricut
fever to predict the number of runs a
player would score in the coming matches
based on the previous performance I'm
sure you can figure out other
applications you could use linear
regression four so let's jump in and
let's understand linear regression and
dig into the theory understanding linear
regression linear regression is the
statistical model used to predict the
relationship between independent and
dependent variables by examining two
factors the first important one is which
variables in particular are significant
predictors of the outcome variable and
the second one that we need to look at
closely is how significant is the
regression line to make predictions with
with the highest possible accuracy if
it's inaccurate we can't use it so it's
very important we find out the most
accurate line we can get since linear
regression is based on drawing a line
through data we're going to jump back
and take a look at some ukian geometry
the simplest form of a simple linear
regression equation with one dependent
and one independent variable is
represented by y equals m * x + C and if
you look at our model here we plotted
two points on here uh X1 and y1 X2 and
Y2 y being the dependent variable
remember that from before and X being
the independent variable so y depends on
whatever X is m in this case is the
slope of the line where m equals the
difference in the Y 2 - y1 and X2 - X1
and finally we have C which is the
coefficient of the line or where happens
to cross the zero axis let's go back and
look at an example we used earlier of
linear regression we're going to go back
to plotting the amount of crop yield
based on the amount of rainfall and here
we have our rainfall remember we cannot
change rainfall and we have our crop
yield which is dependent on the rainfall
so we have our independent and our
dependent variables we're going to take
this and draw a line through it as best
we can through the middle of the data
and then we look at that we put the red
point on the Y AIS is the amount of crop
yield you can expect for the amount of
rainfall represented by the Green Dot so
if we have an idea what the rainfall is
for this year and what's going on then
we can guess how good our crops are
going to be and we've created a nice
line right through the middle to give us
a nice mathematical formula let's take a
look and see what the math looks like
behind this let's look at the intuition
behind the regression line now before we
dive into the math and the formulas that
go behind this and what's going on
behind the scenes I want you to note
that when we get into the case study and
we actually apply some python script
that this math that you're going to see
here is already done automatically for
you you don't have to have it memorized
it is however good to have an idea
what's going on so if people reference
the different terms you'll know what
they're talking about let's consider a
sample data set with five rows and find
out how to draw the regression line
we're only going to do five rows because
if we did like the rainfall with
hundreds of points of data that would be
very hard to to see what's going on with
the mathematics so we'll go ahead and
create our own two sets of data and we
have our independent variable X and our
dependent variable Y and when X was 1 we
got yal 2 when X was uh 2 y was four and
so on and so on if we go ahead and plot
this data on a graph we can see how it
forms a nice line through the middle you
can see where it's kind of grouped going
upwards to the right the next thing we
want to know is what the means is of
each of the data coming in the X and the
Y the means doesn't mean anything other
than the average so we add up all the
numbers and divide by the total so 1 + 2
+ 3 + 4 + 5 over 5 = 3 and the same for
y we get four if we go ahead and plot
the means on the graph we'll see we get
3 comma 4 which draws a nice line down
the middle a good estimate here we're
going to dig deeper into the math behind
the regression line now remember before
I said you don't have to have all these
formulas memorized or fully understand
them even though we're going to go into
a little more detail of how it works and
if you're not a math whz and you don't
know if you've never seen the sigma
character before which looks a little
bit like an e that's opened up that just
means summation that's all that is so
when you see the sigma character it just
means we're adding everything in that
row and for computers this is great
because as a programmer you can easily
iterate through each of the XY points
and create all the information you need
so in the top half you can see where
we've broken that down into pieces and
as it goes through the first two points
it computes the squared value of x the
squared value of y and x * Y and then it
takes all of X and adds them up all of Y
adds them up all of X squ adds them up
and so on and so on and you can see we
have the sum of equal to 15 the sum is
equal to 20 all the way up to x * Y
where the sum equal 66 this all comes
from our formula for calculating a
straight line where y equal the slope *
X plus the coefficient C so we go down
below and we're going to compute more
like the averages of these and we're
going to explain exactly what that is in
just a minute and where that information
comes from it's called the square means
error but we'll go into that in detail
in a few minutes all you need to do is
look at the formula and see how we've
gone about Computing it line by line
instead of trying to have a huge set of
numbers pushed into it and down here
you'll see where the slope m equals and
then the top part if you read through
the brackets you have the number of data
points times the sum of x * Y which we
computed one line at a time there and
that's just the 66 and take all that and
you subtract it from the sum of x times
the sum of Y and those have both been
computed so you have 15 * 20 and on the
bottom we have the number of lines times
the sum of X squar easily computed as 86
for the sum minus I'll take all that and
subtract the sum of x^ s and we end up
as we come across with our formula you
can plug in all those numbers which is
very easy to do on the computer you
don't have to do the math on a piece of
paper or calculator and you'll get a
slope of 6 and you'll get your C
coefficient if you continue to follow
through that formula you'll see it comes
out as equal to 2.2 continuing deeper
into what's going behind the scenes
let's find out the predicted values of Y
for corresponding values of X using the
linear equation where m equal 6 and C =
2.2 we're going to take these values and
we're going to go ahead and plot them
we're going to predict them so y = 6 *
where x = 1 + 2.2 = 2.8 so on and so on
and here the Blue Points represent the
actual y values and the brown points
represent the predicted yv values based
on the model we created the distance
between the actual and predicted values
is known as residuals or errors the best
fit line should have the least sum of
squares of these errors also known as e
square if we put these into a nice chart
where you can see X and you can see Y
where the actual values were and you can
see y predicted you can easily see where
we take Yus y predicted and we get an
answer what is the difference between
those two and if we square that Yus y
prediction squared we can then sum those
squared values that's where we get the
64 plus the 36 + 1 all the way down
until we have a summation equals 2.4 so
the sum of squared errors for this
regression line is 2.4 we check this
error for each line and conclude the
best fit line having the least e Square
value in a nice graphical representation
we can see here where we keep moving
this line through the data points to
make sure the best fit line has the
least Square distance between the data
points and the regression line now we
only looked at the most commonly used
formula for minimizing the distance
there there are lots of ways to minimize
the distance between the line and the
data points like sum of squared errors
sum of absolute errors root mean square
error Etc what you want to take away
from this is whatever formula is being
used you can easily using a computer
programming and iterating through the
data calculate the different parts of it
that way these complicated formulas you
see with the different summations and
absolute values are easily computed one
piece at a time up until this point we
only been looking at two values X and Y
well in the real world it's very rare
that you only have two values when
you're figuring out a solution so let's
move on to the next topic multiple
linear regression let's take a brief
look at what happens when you have
multiple inputs so in multiple linear
regression we have uh well we'll start
with the simple linear regression where
we had y = m + x + C and we're trying to
find the value of y now with multiple
linear regression we have multiple
variables coming in so instead of having
just X we have X1 X2 X3 and instead of
having just one slope each variable has
its own slope attached to it as you can
see here we have M1 M2 M3 and we still
just have the single coefficient so when
you're dealing with multiple linear
regression you basically take your
single linear regression and you spread
it out so you have yal M1 * X1 + M2 * X2
so on all the way to m to the n x to the
and then you add your coefficient on
there implementation of linear
regression now we get into my favorite
part let's understand how multiple
linear regression works by implementing
it in Python if you remember before we
were looking at a company and just based
on its R&D trying to figure out its
profit we're going to start looking at
the expenditure of the company we're
going to go back to that we're going to
predict its profit but instead of
predicting it just on the R&D we're
going to look at other factors like
Administration costs marketing costs and
so on and from there we're going to see
if we can figure out what the profit of
that company's going to be to start our
coding we're going to begin by importing
some basic libraries and we're going to
be looking through the data before we do
any kind of linear regression we're
going to take a look at the data see
what we're playing with then we'll go
ahead and format the data to the format
we need to be able to run it in the
linear regression model and then from
there we'll go ahead and solve it and
just see how valid our solution is so
let's start with importing the basic
libraries now I'm going to be doing this
in Anaconda Jupiter notebook a very
popular IDE I enjoy it it's such a
visual to look at and it's so easy to
use um just any ID for python will work
just fine for this so break out your
favorite python IDE so here we are in
our Jupiter notebook let me go ahead and
paste our first piece of code in there
and let's walk through what libraries
we're importing first we're going to
import numpy as NP and then I want you
to skip one line and look at import
pandas as PD these these are very common
tools that you need with most of your
linear regression the numpy which stands
for number python is usually denoted as
NP and you have to almost have that for
your sklearn toolbox you always import
that right off the beginning pandas
although you don't have to have it for
your sklearn libraries it does such a
wonderful job of importing data setting
it up into a data frame so we can
manipulate it rather easily and it has a
lot of tools also in addition to that so
we usually like to use the pandas when
we can and I'll show you what that looks
like the other three lines are for us to
get a visual of this data and take a
look at it so we're going to import
matplot library. pyplot as PLT and then
caborn as SNS caborn works with the
matplot library so you have to always
import matplot library and then caborn
sits on top of it and we'll take a look
at what that looks like you could use
any of your own plotting libraries you
want there's all kinds of ways to look
at the data these are just very common
ones and the caborn is so easy to use it
just looks beautiful it's a nice
representation that you can actually
take and show somebody and the final
line is the Amber sign map plot library
in line that is only because I'm doing
an inline IDE my interface in the
Anaconda Jupiter notebook requires I put
that in there or you're not going to see
the graph when it comes up let's go
ahead and run this it's not going to be
that interesting because we're just
setting up variables in fact it's not
going to do anything that we can see but
it is importing these different
libraries and setup the next step is
load the data set and extract
independent dep and dependent variables
now here in the slide you'll see
companies equals pd. read CSV and it has
a long line there with the file at the
end 1,000 companies. CSV you're going to
have to change this to fit whatever
setup you have and the file itself you
can request just go down to the
commentary below this video and put a
note in there and simply learn we'll try
to get in contact with you and Supply
you with that file so you can try this
coding yourself so we're going to add
this code in here and we're going to see
that I have companies equals pd. reader
CSV and I've changed this path to match
my computer c/s simplylearn
1000 companies. CSV and then below there
we're going to set the x equals to
companies under the ication and because
this is companies is a PD data set I can
use this nice notation that says take
every row that's what the colon the
first colon is comma except for the last
column that's what the second part is
where we have a colon minus one and we
want the values set into there so X is
no longer a data set a pandis data set
but we can easily extract the data from
our pandis data set with this notation
and then why we're going to set equal to
the last row well the question is going
to be what are we actually looking at so
let's go ahead and take a look at that
and we're going to look at the
companies. head which lists the first
five rows of data and I'll open up the
file in just a second so you can see
where that's coming from but let's look
at the data in here as far as the way
the panda sees it when I hit run you'll
see it breaks it out into a nice setup
this is what pandas one of the things
pandas is really good about is it looks
just like an Excel spreadsheet you have
your rows and remember when we're
programming we always start with zero we
don't start with one so it shows the
first five rows 0 1 2 34 and then it
shows your different columns R&D spend
Administration marketing spend State
profit it even notes that the top are
column names it was never told that but
pandas is able to recognize a lot of
things that they're not the same as the
data rows why don't we go ahead and open
this file up in a CSV so you can
actually see the raw data so here I've
opened it up as a text editor and you
can see at the top we have R&D spin
comma Administration comma marketing
spin comma State comma profit carriage
return I don't know about you but I'd go
crazy trying to read files like this
that's why we use the pandas you could
also open this up in an Excel and it
would separate it since it is a comma
separated variable file but we don't
want to look at this one we want to look
at something we can read rather EAS
easily so let's flip back and take a
look at that top part the first five row
now as nice as this format is where I
can see the data to me it doesn't mean a
whole lot maybe you're an expert in
business and Investments and you
understand what
$165,300 compared to the administration
cost of
$136,800 so on so on helps to create the
profit of
192,25
183 that makes no sense to me whatsoever
no pun intended so let's flip back here
and take a look at our next set of code
where we're going to graph it so we can
get a better understanding of our data
and what it means so at this point we're
going to use a single line of code to
get a lot of information so we can see
where we're going with this let's go
ahead and paste that into our uh
notebook and see what we got going and
so we have the visualization and again
we're using SNS which is pandas as you
can see we imported the map plot
library. pyplot as PL T which then the
caborn uses and we imported the caborn
as SNS and then that final line of code
helps us show this in our um inline
coding without this it wouldn't display
and you could display it to a file and
other means and that's the matap plot
Library inline with the Amber sign at
the beginning so here we come down to
the single line of code caborn is great
because it actually recognizes the panda
data frame so I can just take the
companies. core for coordinates and I
can put that right into the caborn and
when we run this we get this beautiful
plot and let's just take a look at what
this plot means if you look at this plot
on mine the colors are probably a little
bit more purplish and blue than the
original one uh we have the columns and
the rows we have R and D spinning we
have Administration we have marketing
spending and profit and if you cross
index any two of these since we're
interested in profit if you cross index
profit with profit it's going to show up
if you look at the scale on the right
way up in the dark why because those are
the same data they have an exact
correspondence so R&D spending is going
to be the same as R&D spending and the
same thing with Administration Coster
right down the middle you get this dark
row or dark um diagonal row that shows
that this is the highest corresponding
data that's exactly the same and as it
becomes lighter there's less connections
between the data so we can see with
profit obviously profit is the same as
profit and next it has a very high
correlation with R&D spending which we
let at earlier and it has a slightly
less connection to marketing spending
and even less to how much money we put
into the administration so now that we
have a nice look at the data let's go
ahead and dig in and create some actual
useful linear regression models so that
we can predict values and have a better
profit now that we've taken a look at
the visualization of this data we're
going to move on to the next step
instead of just having a pretty picture
we need to generate some hard data some
hard values so let's see what that looks
like we're going to set up our linear
regression model in two steps the first
one is we need to prepare some of our
data so it fits correctly and let's go
ahead and paste this code into our
Jupiter notebook and what we're bringing
in is we're going to bring in the
sklearn pre-processing where we're going
to import the label encoder and the one
hot encoder to use the label encoder
we're going to create a variable called
label encoder and set it equal to
capital L label capital E encoder this
creates a class that we can reuse for
transferring the labels back and forth
now about now you should ask what labels
are we talking about let's go take a
look at the data we processed before and
see what I'm talking about here if you
remember when we did the companies. head
and we printed the top five rows of data
we have our columns going across we have
column zero which is R&D spending column
one which is Administration column two
which is marketing spending and column
three is State and you'll see under
State we have New York California
Florida now to do a linear regression
model it doesn't know how to process New
York it knows how to process a number so
the first thing we're going to do is
we're going to change that New York
California and Florida and we're going
to change those to numbers that's what
this line of code does here x equals and
then it has the colon comma 3 in
Brackets the first part the colon comma
means that we're going to look at all
the different rows so we're going to
keep them all together but the only row
we're going to edit is the third row and
in there we're going to take the label
coder and we're going to fit and
transform the X also the third row so
we're going to take that third row we're
going to set it equal to a
transformation and that transformation
basically tells it that instead of
having a uh New York it has a zero or
one or a two and then finally we need to
do a one hot encoder which equals one
hot encoder categorical features equals
three and then we take the X and we go
ahead and do that equal to one hot
encoder fit transform X to array this
final transformation preps our data
Force so it's completely set the way we
need it as just a row of numbers even
though it's not in here let's go ahead
and print X and just take a look what
this data is doing you'll see I have an
array of arrays and then each array is a
row of numbers and if I go ahead and
just do row zero you'll see I have a
nice organized row of numbers that the
computer now understands we'll go ahead
and take this out there because it
doesn't mean a whole lot to us it's just
a row of numbers next on setting up our
data we have avoiding dummy variable
trap this is very important why because
the computer has automatically
transformed our header into the setup
and it's automatically transformed all
these different variables so when we did
the encoder the encoder created two
columns and what we need to do is just
have the one because it has both the
variable and the name that's what this
piece of code does here let's go ahead
and paste this in here and we have xal X
colon comma 1 colon all this is doing is
removing that one extra column we put in
there when we did our one hot encoder
and our label en coding let's go ahead
and run that and now we get to create
our linear regression model and let's
see what that looks like here and we're
going to do that in two steps the first
step is going to be in splitting the
data now whenever we create a uh
predictive model of data we always want
to split it up so we have a training set
and we have a testing set that's very
important otherwise we'd be very
unethical without testing it to see how
good our fit is and then we'll go ahead
and create our multiple linear
regression model and train it and set it
up let's go ahead and paste this next
piece of code in here and I'll go ahead
and shrink it down a size or two so it
all fits on one line so from the sklearn
module selection we're going to import
train test split and you'll see that
we've created four completely different
variables we have capital x train
capital X test smaller case y train
smaller case y test that is the standard
way that they usually reference es when
we're doing different uh models usually
see that a capital x and you see the
train and the test and the lowercase Y
what this is is X is our data going in
that's our R&D spin our Administration
our marketing and then Y which we're
training is the answer that's the profit
because we want to know the profit of an
unknown entity so that's what we're
going to shoot for in this tutorial the
next part train test split we take X and
we take y we've already created those X
has the columns with the data in it and
Y has a column with profit in it and
then we're going to set the test size
equals 0.2 that basically means 20% So
20% of the rows are going to be tested
we're going to put them off to the side
so since we're using a th lines of data
that means that 200 of those lines we're
going to hold off to the side to test
for later and then the random State
equals zero we're going to randomize
which ones it picks to hold off to the
side we'll go ahead and run this it's
not overly exciting it's setting up our
variables but the next step is the next
step we actually create our linear
regression model now that we got to the
linear regression model we get that next
piece of the puzzle let's go and put
that code in there and walk through it
so here we go we're going to paste it in
there and let's go ahead and since this
is a shorter line of code let's zoom up
there so we can get a good look and we
have from the SK learn. linear model
we're going to import linear regression
now I don't know if you recall from
earlier when we were doing all the math
let's go ahead and flip back there and
take a look at that do you remember this
or we had this long formula on the
bottom and we were doing all this suiz
and then we also looked at setting it up
with the different lines and then we
also looked all the way down to multiple
linear regression where we're adding all
those formulas together all of that is
wrapped up in this one section so what's
going on here is I'm going to create a
variable called regressor and the
regressor equals the linear regression
that's a linear regression model that
has all that math built in so we don't
have to have it all memorized or have to
compute it individually and then we do
the the regressor do fet in this case we
do X train and Y train because we're
using the training data X being the data
in and Y being profit what we're looking
at and this does all that math for us so
within one click and one line we've
created the whole linear regression
model and we fit the data to the linear
regression model and you can see that
when I run the regressor it gives an
output linear regression it says copy
xals True Fit intercept equals true in
jobs equal one normalize equals false
it's just giving you some general
information on what's going on with that
regressor model now that we've created
our linear regression model let's go
ahead and use it and if you remember we
kept a bunch of data aside so we're
going to do a y predict variable and
we're going to put in the X test and
let's see what that looks like scroll up
a little bit paste that in here
predicting the test set results so here
we have y predict equals regressor do
predict X test going in and this gives
us y predict now because I'm in Jupiter
inline I can just put the variable up
there and when I hit the Run button
it'll print that array out I could have
just is easily done print y predict so
if you're in a different IDE that's not
an inline setup like the Jupiter
notebook you can do it this way print y
predict and you'll see that for the 200
different test variables we kept off to
the side it's going to produce 200
answers this is what it says the profit
are for those 200 predictions but let's
don't stop there let's keep going and
take a couple look we're going to take
just a short detail here and calculating
the coefficients and the intercepts this
gives us a quick flash at what's going
on behind the line we're going to take a
short detour here and we're going to be
calculating the coefficient and
intercepts so you can see what those
look like what's really nice about our
regressor we created is it already has a
coefficients for us and we can simply
just print regressor do coefficient
underscore when I run this you'll see
our coefficients here and if we can do
the regressor coefficient ient we can
also do the regressor intercept and
let's run that and take a look at that
this all came from the multiple
regression model and we'll flip over so
you can remember where this is going
into and where it's coming from you can
see the formula down here where y = M1 *
X1 + M2 * X2 and so on and so on plus C
the coefficient so these variables fit
right into this formula y equal slope 1
* column 1 variable plus slope 2 *
column 2 variable all the way to the m
to the n and x to the N plus C the
coefficient or in this case you have -
8.89 to the power of two etc etc times
the First Column and the second column
and the third column and then our
intercept is the minus1
0309 point boy it gets kind of
complicated when you look at it this is
why we don't do this by hand anymore
this is why we have the computer to make
these calculations easy to understand
and calculate now I told you that was a
short detour and we're coming towards
the end of our script as you remember
from the beginning I said if we're going
to divide this information we have to
make sure it's a valid model that this
model works and understand how good it
works so calculating the r SAR value
that's what we're going to use to
predict how good our prediction is and
let's take a look at what that looks
like in code and so we're going to use
this from sklearn docs we're going to
import R2 score that's the R squar value
we're looking at the error so in the R2
score we take our y test versus our y
predict y test is the actual values
we're testing that was the one that was
given to us so we know our true the Y
predict of those 200 values is what we
think it was true and when we go ahead
and run this we see we get a
9352 that's the R2 score now it's not
exactly a straight percentage so it's
not saying it's 93% correct but you do
want that in the upper 90s o and higher
shows that this is a very valid
prediction based on the R2 two score and
if r squar value of 91 or 92 as we got
on our model remember it does have a
random generation involved this proves
the model is a good model which means
success yay we successfully trained our
model with certain predictors and
estimated the profit of the companies
using linear regression thank you for a
really great session Richard I hope you
guys found linear regression fun to
learn now let's get into some other
machine learning algorithms over to moan
hello hello and welcome to the session
on logistic regression I'm moan Kumar
from Simply learn what is logistic
regression as I mentioned earlier
logistic regression is an algorithm for
performing binary classification so
let's take an example and see how this
works let's say your car has not been
serviced for quite a few years and now
you want to find out if it is going to
break down in the near future so this is
like a classification problem find out
whether your car will break down or not
so how are we going to perform this
classification so here's how it looks if
we plot the information along the X and
Y AIS X is the number of years since the
last service was performed and Y is the
probability of your car breaking down
and let's say this information was this
data rather was collected from several
car users it's not just your car but
several car users so that is our labeled
data so the data has been collected and
um for for the number of years and when
the car broke down and what was the
probability and that has been plotted
along X and Y AIS so this provides an
idea or from this graph we can find out
whether your car will break down or not
we'll see how so first of all the
probability can go from 0 to one as you
all aware probability can be between
zero and one and as we can imagine it is
intuitive as well as the number of years
are on the Lower Side maybe one year two
years or 3 years till after the service
the chances of your car breaking down
are very limited right so for example
chances of your car breaking down or the
probability of your car breaking down
within 2 years of your last service are
0.1 probability similarly 3 years is
maybe3 and so on but as the number of
years increases let's say if it was 6 or
7 years there is almost a certainty that
your car is going to break down that is
what this graph shows so this is an
example of a application of the
classification algorithm and we will see
in little details how exactly logistic
regression is applied here one more
thing needs to be added here is that the
dependent variables outcome is discrete
so if we are talking about whether the
car is going to break down or not so
that is a discrete value the Y that we
are talking about the dependent variable
that we are talking about what we are
looking at is whether the car is going
to break down or not yes or no that is
what we are talking about so here the
outcome is discrete and not a continuous
value so this is how the logistic
regression curve looks let me explain a
little bit what exactly and how exactly
we are going to uh determine the class
at the outcome rather so for a logistic
regression curve a threshold has to be
set saying that because this is a
probability calculation remember this is
a probability calculation and the
probability itself will not be zero or
one but based on the probability we need
to decide what the outcome should be so
there has to be a threshold like for
example 0.5 can be the threshold let's
say in this case so any value of the
probability below 0.5 is considered to
be zero and any value above 0.5 is
considered to be one so an output of
let's
say8 will mean that the car will break
down so that is considered as an output
of one and let's say an output of. 29 is
considered as zero which means that the
car will not break down so that's the
way logistic regression works now let's
do a quick comparison between logistic
regression and linear regression because
they both have the term regression in
them so that can cause confusion
so let's try to remove that confusion so
what is linear regression linear
regression is a process is once again an
algorithm for supervised learning
however here you're going to find a
continuous value you're going to
determine a continuous value it could be
the price of a real estate property it
could be your hike how much hike you're
going to get or it could be a stock
price these are all continuous values
these are not discrete compared to a yes
or a no kind of a response that we are
looking for for in logistic regression
so this is one example of a linear
regression let's say at the HR team of a
company tries to find out what should be
the salary hike of an employee so they
collect all the details of their
existing employees their ratings and
their salary hikes what has been given
and that is the labeled information that
is available and the system learns from
this it is train and it learns from this
labeled information so that when a new
employees information is fed based on on
the rating it will determine what should
be the height so this is a linear
regression problem and a linear
regression example now salary is a
continuous value you can get 5,000
5,500 5,600 it is not discrete like a
cat or a dog or an apple or a banana
these are discrete or a yes or a no
these are discrete values right so this
where you are trying to find continuous
values is where we use linear regression
so let's say just to extend on this
scenario we now want to find out whether
this employee is going to get a
promotion or not so we want to find out
that is a discrete problem right a yes
or no kind of a problem in this case we
actually cannot use linear regression
even though we may have labeled data so
this is the labeled data So based on the
employee rating these are the ratings
and then some people got the promotion
and this is the ratings for which people
did not get promotion that is a no and
this is the rating for which people got
promotion we just plotted the data about
whether a person has got an employe has
got promotion or not yes no right so
there is nothing in between and what is
the employees rating okay and ratings
can be continuous that is not an issue
but the output is discrete in this case
whether employee got promotion yes no
okay so if we try to plot that and we
try to find find a straight line this is
how it would look and as you can see
doesn't look very right because looks
like there will be lot of errors this
root mean square error if you remember
for linear regression would be very very
high and also the the values cannot go
beyond zero or Beyond one so the graph
should probably look somewhat like this
clipped at zero and one but still the
straight line doesn't look right
therefore instead of using a linear
equation we need to come up with
something different and therefore the
logistic regression model looks somewhat
like this so we calculate the
probability and if we plot that
probability not in the form of a
straight line but we need to use some
other equation we will see very soon
what that equation is then it is a
gradual process right so you see here
people with some of these ratings are
not getting any promotions and then
slowly uh at certain rating they get
promotion so that is a gradual process
and uh this is how the math behind
logistic regression looks so we are
trying to find the odds for a particular
event happening and this is the formula
for finding the odds so the probability
of an event happening divided by the
probability of the event not happening
so P if it is the probability of the
event happening probability of the
person getting a promotion and divided
by the probability of the person not
getting a promotion that is 1 minus
P so this is how you measure the odds
now the values of the odds range from
0er to Infinity so when this probability
is zero then the odds will the value of
the odds is equal to Zer and when the
probability becomes one then the value
of the odds is 1 by 0 that will be
Infinity but the probability itself
remains between 0 and 1 now this is how
an equation of a straight line look so Y
is equal to Beta 0 plus beta 1 x where
beta 0 is the Y intercept and beta 1 is
the slope of the line if we take the
odds equation and take a log of both
sides then this would look somewhat like
this and the term logistic is actually
derived from the fact that we are doing
this we take a log of PX by 1 minus PX
this is an extension of the calculation
of odds that we have seen right and that
is equal to Beta 0 + beta 1 x which is
the equation of the straight line and
now from here if you want to find out
the value of PX you will see we can take
the exponential on both sides and then
if we solve that equation we will get
the equation of PX like this PX is equal
to 1 by 1 + e ^ of minus beta 0 + beta 1
x and recall this is nothing but the
equation of the line which is equal to y
y is equal to Beta 0 + beta 1X so that
this is the equation also known as the
sigmoid function and this is the
equation of the logistic regression Al
all right and if this is plotted this is
how the sigmoid curve is obtained so
let's compare linear and logistic
regression how they are different from
each other let's go back so linear
regression is solved or used to solve
regression problems and logistic
regression is used to solve
classification problems so both are
called regression but linear regression
is used for solving regression problems
where we predict continuous values
whereas logistic regression is used for
solving classification problems where we
have have to predict discrete values the
response variables in case of linear
regression are continuous in nature
whereas here they are categorical or
discrete in nature and um linear
regression helps to estimate the
dependent variable when there is a
change change in the independent
variable whereas here in case of
logistic regression it helps to
calculate the probability or the
possibility of a particular event
happening and linear regression as the
name suggests is a straight line that's
why it's called linear regression
whereas logistic regression is a sigmoid
function and the curve is the shape of
the curve is s it's an s-shaped curve
this is another example of application
of logistic regression in weather
prediction whether it's going to rain or
not rain now keep in mind both are used
in weather prediction if we want to find
the discrete values like whether it's
going to rain or not rain that is a
classification problem we use logistic
regression but if we want to determine
what is going to be the temperature
tomorrow then we use linear regression
so just keep in mind that in weather
prediction we actually use both but
these are some examples of logistic
regression so we want to find out
whether it's going to be rain or not
it's going to be sunny or not it's going
to snow or not these are all logistic
regression examples a few more examples
classification of objects this is a
again another example of logistic
regression now here of course one
distinction is that these are multiclass
classification so logistic regression is
not used in its original form but it is
used in a slightly different form so we
say whether it is a dog or not a dog I
hope you understand so instead of saying
is it a dog or a cat or elephant we
convert this into saying so because we
need to keep it to Binary classification
so we say is it a dog or not a dog is it
a cat or not a cat so that's the way
logistic regression can be used for
classifying objects otherwise there are
other techniques which can be used for
performing multiclass classification in
healthcare logistic regression is used
to find the survival rate of a patient
so they take multiple parameters like
trauma score and age and so on and so
forth and they try to predict the rate
of survival all right now finally let's
take an example and see how we can apply
logistic regression to predict the
number that is shown in the image so
this is actually a live demo I will take
you into Jupiter notebook and um show
the code but before that let me take you
through a couple of slides to explain
what we're trying to do so let's say you
have an 8 by8 image and the image has a
number 1 2 3 4 and you need to train
your model to predict what this number
is so how do we do this so the first
thing is obviously in any machine
learning process you train your model so
in this case we are using logistic
regression so and then we provide a
training set to train the model and then
we test how accurate our model is with
the test data which means that like any
machine learning process we split our
initial data dat into two parts training
set and test set with the training set
we train our model and then with the
test set we we test the model till we
get good accuracy and then we use it for
for inference right so that is typical
methodology of uh uh training testing
and then deploying of machine learning
models so let's uh take a look at the
code and uh see what we are doing so
I'll not go line by line but just take
you through some of the blocks so first
thing we do is import all the libraries
and then we basically take a look at the
images and see what is the total number
of images we can display using matplot
lip some of the images or a sample of
these images and um then we split the
data into training and test as I
mentioned earlier and we can do some
exploratory analysis and uh then we
build our model we train our model with
the training set and then we test it
with our test set and find out how
accurate our model is is using the
confusion Matrix the heat map and use
heat map for visualizing this and I will
show you in the code what exactly is the
confusion Matrix and how it can be used
for finding the accuracy in our example
we got we get an accuracy of about 0.94
which is pretty good or 94% which is
pretty good all right so what is the
confusion Matrix this is an example of a
confusion Matrix and uh this is used for
identifying the accuracy of of a
classification model or like a logistic
regression model so the most important
part in a confusion Matrix is that first
of all this as you can see this is a
matrix and the size of the Matrix
depends on how many outputs uh we are
expecting right so the the most
important part here is that the model
will be most accurate when we have the
maximum numbers in its diagonal like in
this case that's why it has almost 93
94% because the diagonals should have
the maximum numbers and the others other
than diagonals the cells other than the
diagonals should have very few numbers
so here that's what is happening so
there is a two here there are there's a
one here but most of them are along the
diagonal this what does this mean this
means that the number that has been fed
is zero and the number that has been
detected is also zero so the predicted
value and the actual value are the same
so along the diagonals that is true
which means that let's let's take this
diagonal right if if the maximum number
is here that means that like here in
this case it is 34 which means that 34
of the images that have been fed or
rather actually there are two
misclassifications in there so 36 images
have been fed which have number four and
out of which 34 have been predicted
correctly as number four and one has
been predicted as number eight and
another one has been predicted as number
nine so these are two
misclassifications okay so that is the
meaning of saying that the maximum
number should be in the diagonal so if
you have all of them so for an ideal
model which has let's say 100% accuracy
everything will be only in the diagonal
there will be no numbers other than zero
in all other cells so that is like a
100% accurate model okay so that's uh
just of how to use this Matrix how to
use this uh confusion Matrix I know the
name uh is a little funny sounding
confusion Matrix but actually it is not
very confusing it's very straightforward
so you just plotting what has been
predicted and what is the labeled
information or what is the actual data
that's also known as the ground truth
sometimes okay these are some fancy
terms that are used so predicted label
and the actual label that's all it is
okay yeah so we are showing a little bit
more information here so 38 have been
predicted and here you will see that all
of them have been predicted correctly
there have been 38 zeros and the the
predicted value and the actual value is
is exactly the same whereas in this case
right it has there are I think 37 + 5
yeah 42 have been fed the images 42
images are of Digit three and uh the
accuracy is only 37 of them have been
accurately predicted three of them have
been predicted as number seven and two
of them have been predicted as number
eight and so on and so forth okay all
right so with that let's go into Jupiter
notebook and see how the code looks so
this is the code in in Jupiter notebook
for logistic regression in this
particular demo what we are going to do
is train our model to recognize digits
which are the images which have digits
from let's say 0 to 5 or 0 to 9 and um
and then we will see how well it is
trained and whether it is able to
predict these numbers correctly or not
so let's get started so the first part
is as usual we are importing some
libraries that are required and uh then
the last line in this block is to load
the digits so let's go ahead and run
this code then here we will visualize
the shape of these uh digits so we can
see here if we take a look this is how
the shape is
1797 by 64 these are like 8 by8 images
so that's that's what is reflected in
this uh shape now from here onwards we
are basically once again importing some
of the libraries that are required like
numpy and map plot and we will take a
look at uh some of the sample images
that we have loaded so this one for
example creates a figure uh and then we
go ahead and take a few sample images to
see how they look so let me run this
code and so that it becomes easy to
understand so these are about five
images sample images that we are looking
at 0 1 2 3 4 so this is how the images
this is how the data is okay and uh
based on this we will actually train our
logistic regression model and then we
will test it and see how well it is able
to recognize so the way it works is the
pixel information so as you can see here
this is an 8 by 8 pixel kind of a image
and uh the each pixel whether it is
activated or not activated that is the
information available for each pixel now
based on the pattern of this activation
and non-activation of the various pixels
this will be identified as a zero for
example right similarly as you can see
so overall each of these numbers
actually has a different pattern of of
the pixel activation and that's pretty
much that our model needs to learn for
which number what is the pattern of the
activation of the pixels right so that
is what we are going to train our model
okay so the first thing we need to do is
to split our data into training and test
data set right so whenever we perform
any training we split the data into
training and test so that the training
data set is used to train the system so
we pass this probably multiple times uh
and then we test it with the test data
set and the split is usually in the form
of there and there are various ways in
which you can split this data it is up
to the individual preferences in our
case here we are splitting in the form
of 23 and 77 so when we say test size as
20. 23 that means 23% of the entire data
is used for testing and the remaining
77% is used for training so there is a
readily available function which is uh
called train test split so we don't have
to write any special code for the
splitting it will automatically split
the data based on the proportion that we
give here which is test size so we just
give the test size automatically
training size will be determined and uh
we pass the a data that we want to split
and the the results will be stored in
xcore train
and Yore train for the training data set
and what is xcore train this are these
are the features right which is like the
independent variable and Yore train is
the label right so in this case what
happens is we have the input value which
is or the features value which is in
xcore train and since this is labeled
data for each of them each of the
observations we already have the label
information saying whether this digit is
a zero or a one or a two so that this
this is what will be used for comparison
to find out whether the the system is
able to recognize it correctly or there
is an error for each observation it will
compare with this right so this is the
label so the same way xcore train ycore
train is for the training data set xcore
test Yore test is for the test data set
okay so let me go ahead and execute this
code as well and then we can go and
check quickly what what is the how many
entries are there and in each of this so
xcore train the shape is
1383 by 64 and ycore train has 1383
because there is uh nothing like the
second part is not required here and
then xcore test shape we see is 414 so
actually there are 414 observations in
test and 1383 observations in train so
that's basically what these four lines
of code are are saying okay then we
import the logistic regression library
and uh which is a part of Psy it learn
so we we don't have to implement the
logistic regression process itself we
just call these the function and uh let
me go ahead and execute that so that uh
we have the logistic regression Library
imported now we create an instance of
logistic regression right so logistic RR
is a is an instance of logis regression
and then we use that for training our
model so let me first execute this code
so these two lines so the first line
basically creates an instance of
logistic regression model and then the
second line is where we are passing our
data the training data set right this is
our the the predictors and uh this is
our Target we are passing this data set
to train our model all right so once we
do this in this case the data is not
large but by and large uh the training
is what takes usually a lot of time so
we spend in machine learning activities
in machine learning projects we spend a
lot of time for the training part of it
okay so here the data set is relatively
small so it was pretty quick so all
right so now our model has been trained
using the training data set and uh we
want to see how accurate this is so what
we'll do is we will test it out in
probably faces so let me first try out
how well this is working for one image
okay I will just try it out with one
image my the first entry in my test data
set and see whether it is uh correctly
predicting or not so and in order to
test it so for training purpose we use
the fit method there is a method called
fit which is for training the model and
once the training is done if you want to
test for uh a particular value new input
you use the predict method okay so let's
run the predict method and we pass this
particular image and uh we see that the
shape is or the prediction is four so
let's try a few more let me see for the
next 10 uh seems to be fine so let me
just go ahead and test the entire data
set okay that's basically what we will
do so now we want to find out how
accurately this has um performed so we
use the score method to find what is
percentage of accuracy and we see here
that it has performed up to 94% Accurate
okay so that's on this part now what we
can also do is we can um also see this
accuracy using what is known as a
confusion matric so let us go ahead and
try that as well uh so that we can also
visualize how well uh this model has uh
done so let me execute this piece of
code which will basically import some of
the library that are required and um we
we basically create a confusion Matrix
an instance of confusion matrix by
running confusion Matrix and passing
these uh values so we have so this
confusion underscore Matrix method takes
two parameters one is the Yore test and
the other is the prediction so what is
the Yore test these are the labeled
values which we already know for the
test data set and predictions are what
the system has predicted for the test
data set okay so this is known to us and
this is what the system has uh the model
has generated so we kind of create the
confusion Matrix and we will printed and
this is how the confusion Matrix looks
as the name suggests it is a matrix and
um the key point out here is that the
accuracy of the model is determined by
how many numbers are there there in the
diagonal the more the numbers in the
diagonal the better the accuracy is okay
and first of all the total sum of all
the numbers in this whole Matrix is
equal to the number of observations in
the test data set that is the first
thing right so if you add up all these
numbers that will be equal to the number
of observations in the test data set and
then out of that the maximum number of
them should be in the diagonal that
means the accuracy is predic good if the
numbers in the diagonal are less and in
all other places there are a lot of
numbers which means the accuracy is very
low the diagonal indicates a correct
prediction that this means that the
actual value is same as the predicted
value here again actual value is same as
the predicted value and so on right so
the moment you see a number here that
means the actual value is something and
the predicted value is something else
right similarly here the actual value is
something and the predicted value is
something else so that is is basically
how we read the confusion Matrix now how
do we find the accuracy you can actually
add up the total values in the diagonal
so it's like 38 + 44 Plus 43 and so on
and divide that by the total number of
test observations that will give you the
percentage accuracy using a confusion
Matrix now let us visualize this
confusion Matrix in a slightly more
sophisticated way uh using a heat map so
we will create a heat map with some
we'll add some colors as well it's uh
it's like a more visually visually more
appealing so that's the whole idea so if
we let me run this piece of code and
this is how the heat map uh looks uh and
as you can see here the diagonals again
are are all the values are here most of
the values so which means reasonably the
seems to be reasonably accurate and yeah
basically the accuracy score is 94% this
is calculated as I mentioned by adding
all these numbers divided by the total
test values or the total number of
observations in test data set okay so
this is the confusion Matrix for
logistic
regression all right so now that we have
seen the confusion Matrix let's take a
quick sample and see how well uh the
system has classified and we will take a
few examples of the data so if we see
here we we picked up randomly a few of
them so this is uh number four which is
the actual value and also the predicted
value both are four this is an image of
zero so the predicted value is also zero
actual value is of course zero then this
is the image of nine so this is also
been predicted correctly N9 and actual
value is N9 and this is the image of one
and again this has been predicted
correctly as like the actual value Okay
so this was a quick demo of logistic
regression how to use logistic
regression to identify
images staying ahead in your career
requires continuous learning and
upscaling whether you're a student
aiming to learn today's top skills or a
working professional looking to advance
your career we've got you covered
explore our impressive catalog of
certification programs in cuttingedge
domains including data science cloud
computing cyber security AI machine
learning or digital marketing designed
in collaboration with leading
universities and top corporations and
delivered by industry experts choose any
of our programs and set yourself on the
path to Career Success click the link in
the description to know
more hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learn YouTube
channel and click here to watch similar
videos to ner up and get certified click
here